when I'm with him I feel yes I am living  and when I'm not with him yes everything  does seem sort of silly I don't mean  with you I never with you that's all the  rest of it Sally the rest of it  false comfort because if you say to me  when were you happy mom tell me the  moment you were happiest I know I know  it was years ago  yeah all you're saying is you were once  young I remember one morning getting up  at dawn there was such a sense of  possibility you know but feeling and I  remember thinking to myself so this is  the beginning of happiness this is where  it starts and of course they'll always  be more never occurred to me it wasn't  the beginning it was happiness it was  the moment right then  [Music]